Speaker 1: I mentioned yesterday that we'd
be talking about this briefly today.
Donald Trump has been reduced to ranting about
the 2020 election in what is now almost the
year 2020 to to dinner guests who are seemingly
just trying to have have a nice dinner.
And when we asked the question, Does Trump
really believe this stuff when he says it?
Does Trump really believe that he won the
2020 election?
Does Trump really believe that there were
massive dumps of fake ballots or whatever
the case?
This video that I'm going to play for you
is in the he does believe it sort of category
because I think that if he's ranting at people
at a random dinner, it suggests to me that
he thinks it's real.
But he might just be that much of a narcissist
that he feels like he has to keep the lie
going at all times.
I don't know.
Let's take a look at the video and tell me
what you think.
And also consider just how humiliating it
is that 13 months after losing an election,
pretty badly.
This is what a former president is up to 11
months after leaving office, ranting at a
dinner to guests that he actually won.
And as a little bonus, at about the 75 second
mark, you're going to see one of the guys
in the background look at his watch, which
is just, I mean, it's it's bonus points at
this point.
Take a look.
Speaker 7: If you get the same number, which
was 63 million, did that less and you can't
lose if you got one million more, it's guaranteed
I got 12 million more.
No president has ever gotten anything like
that.
There's never been anybody that got 12 million
more.
We got the guy who's with us.
It's not me if we are really is we and we
did so well.
And then the thing was all rigged in a disgraceful
thing about the mail in ballots, and it was
just horrible.
They mailed hundreds of millions of ballots.
People are getting seven ballots again.
It was somebody else's just randomly I five
that would send to me.
And there's a Democrat who when over there
to give you something positive we will bring
you back is but we're going to have a great
weekend.
We're never going to forget 2020.
We never, you know, the expression water or
we're never going to let it happen.
We're never forgetting it.
We're going to watch it because we can't let
it ever happen again and we continue to pursue
it.
And we will, because so many things like as
an example, Arizona as an example, this comes.
As the example, now, Pennsylvania, with subpoenas
all over the place, which is positive.
In other words, real subpoenas that these
people, you know, these people doing the whatever
you call it, because it was really a protest.
The insurrection took place on Election Day
and the rest was a protest.
And what they should be investigating is the
election, not what took place that day.
They should be because the reason they had
the protest is because of the election.
It's very simple.
Speaker 1: Isn't that truly something?
I mean, it's it's like a broken record, but
and embarrassing and pathetic broken record.
And I have to tell you watching that I realized
how much I don't miss having those rants every
single day in the corporate media narrative.
And thanks to Trump being banned from Twitter.
They also aren't on Twitter.
But what is the future for this guy?
He seems to have completely lost it.
Humiliated globally, the laughing stock of
the world.
Most of the world glad he's gone.
With very few exceptions, Russia's an exception.
Russians liked Trump.
There were one or two, I think it was, was
it Turkey and Nigeria?
I don't I don't remember now, with very few
exceptions, the world's citizens are glad
that Trump is gone.
He's a legend in his own mind, but his devoted
followers want him back.
We know that every poll of Republicans tells
us that, and if we're not careful, he could
well end up back in office.
One less thing that's just kind of funny.
I've talked before about these linguistic
tells that Trump is lying.
One of them is the most famous.
One is when Trump recounts a story and says,
You know, they came to me, they said, Sir,
whatever he says after that, it's a lie.
The the sir routine, as it's been called,
is a signal that Trump is lying.
Another signal Trump is lying is when he says
something crazy and then says, And it's a
shame, and it's a shame.
So, for example, he'll say, you know, they
did these massive dumps of ballots and stole
the whole thing.
And I really want and it's a shame that it
happened.
That's a signal that Trump is lying.
A third one is and we can never let it happen
again, and we can never let it happen again.
That's another one of these linguistic tools
that Trump is not telling the truth.
And the fourth one would be Trump is speaking
right.
That's like a more a catchall signal that
Trump is not telling
the truth.